Governor Scott as Jonathan just
mentioned is returning to the Florida
Keys today for an update on the recovery
efforts there 80,000 people live in the
keys and we still don't know when all of
them will be allowed to return home the
middle and lower portions of the key
suffered the worst damage from Erma and
they've been closed now for more than a
week Manuel Bojorquez is in the village
of Alamo rata man well good morning good
morning days after the hurricane hit and
you can still there sees there are still
massive piles of debris along the main
highway we're talking about boats wooden
planks and even things that appear to be
from inside people's homes like this
mattress over here crews say they are
making progress having completed
door-to-door checks and finding no
additional victims but without stable
sources of food fuel and clean water in
parts of the keys not all residents are
being allowed back in nearly a week
after hurricane ARMA made its US
landfall crews are racing to bring the
Florida Keys back to life utility
companies are restringing power lines
transportation workers are clearing
roads and the National Guard is rushing
in food and water
in Key West the Coast Guard is
inspecting waterways for wrecked boats
and floating debris and it sits right at
the waterline and if it's covered up by
weeds you won't see it until you hit the
port of Key West which sees nearly a
million cruise passengers a year remains
closed
there's no Key West without the port so
it's critical that we get this open and
safe so vessels will come back in for
many of the thousands of evacuees
desperate to return satellite images
have been the only way to check on the
condition of homes and businesses when
you look down the street and the other
streets and the further down the Keys
you hear these horror stories of people
lost everything for those who have made
at home like Harold Davis despair is
giving way to a new resolve I don't want
to see this but we'll pick up we'll move
on it's it could be allow us Lucy
Morrill says rebuilding and the keys
starts with the people we are the bridge
but you know to keeping this community
alive it's us that work not the houses
not the stuff you know it's us that
rebuilding process is well underway one
of three major hospitals here in the
keys is set to reopen today and
officials in Key West say their island
will be ready for one of the year's
biggest events fantasy fest which is
scheduled to begin October 20th Geoff
many thank you